got a break in line on that some
shipment of PPE that is due to arrive in
the UK from Turkey and let's bring in
our political correspondent Rob Powell
who has more on this and what more do we
know yeah this shipment of protective
equipment that was bound for the NHS
that was due to come in today from
Turkey we understand it will now not
arrive in the UK today now it's not
thought where we're told it's not to do
with a UK side transport or logistics
issue that the transport to get it to
the UK is all in place and ready but
it's more to do with the actual shipment
not being ready to go yet now I think
despite that it is embarrassing for the
government because yesterday in the
Daily Press briefing when challenged on
shortages of especially gowns
Robert gem Rik the community secretary
he was taking that press conference
pointed to the shipment coming in as a
way of those stresses and strains on
supplies of protective equipment being
eased it was 84 tonnes that's due to
come in including 400,000 surgical gowns
which of course seemed to be running in
terms of the supplies at the lowest
level they were subject to that guidance
on Friday evening that workers should
reuse gowns or look for alternatives if
there are shortages now that supply
appears not to be arriving as promised
in the United Kingdom today was Friday
that NHS provider said that over the
next two days some hospitals may run out
of games you imagine the fact that this
shipment is now not going to get here at
least for today will only add to the
stress and strain in some hospitals
around the country